Bill Gates who is now the number one
Farmland owner in the United States has
thousands and thousands of Farmland here
in the United States he has houses all
over the world right on the water
including his like 30 million dollar
mansion in Seattle right on the water
you'd think he'd be freaking out because
the climate change in the water and all
that stuff but don't worry about Bill
Gates he was interviewed by Anderson
Cooper and I Anderson Cooper I actually
think relative to what goes on generally
at CNN and Anderson Cooper is sort of
just nothing right he's not horrific I
guess he's not good you know he's part
of the whole thing but he's not like
just balls out horrible okay uh he
interviewed Bill Gates and he actually
asked him about Bill Gates carbon
footprint because as you know Bill Gates
is flying all over the place his private
planes all of the stuff that he's always
talking about but doesn't seem to really
live in a in a congruent way in his own
life with those things take a look are
you the right Messenger on this because
you fly private plans a lot and you're
creating a lot of greenhouse gases
yourself yeah I'd probably have one of
the highest greenhouse gas Footprints of
anyone on the planet you know my my
personal flying uh alone is gigantic now
I'm
spending quite a bit uh to buy aviation
fuel uh that was made with plants you
know I switched to an electric car I've
used solar panels
unpainted company that actually at a
very high price can pull a bit of carbon
out of the air and stick it underground
and so I'm offsetting my personal
emissions don't worry guys he's taking
carbon out of the air and putting it
underground how do you think that's
going to work out like probably not that
well right they're putting all the
carbon underground and then in five
years from now we're gonna find out boy
you put a lot of carbon underground it
blows a whole bunch of [ __ ] up
he's just a complete hip-hop He's a
hypocrite I was going to try to come up
with something a little more clever
there he's a hypocrite and and an
authoritarian control freak first off I
don't believe that he's offsetting
somehow he has figured out through plant
stuff that he puts in his planes that he
has somehow offset his carbon footprint
you have to understand that this guy
with the amount of houses that he owns
the amount of land that he owns the
planes that he is on I don't begrudge
him any of those things either by the
way as I always say like I am a
capitalist he created something it has
value I don't like the fact that he then
takes all of his money to decide how the
rest of us should live but the idea that
he is somehow offset his carbon
footprint which he admits is gigantic
but good for him he's got an electric
car and solar panels uh the problem is
that he's trying to push all of those
things on everyone else and not everyone
can afford those things that is the
problem
foreign
[Music]